WITH JUAN WILLIAMS,
JESSE WATTERS, DANA PERINO.
"THE FIVE" ."
SOMEONE IN NORTH KOREA READ "THE
ART OF THE DEAL."
BECAUSE NORTH KOREA IS
THREATENING TO CANCEL NEXT
MONTH'S SUMMIT BETWEEN
KIM JONG UN AND PRESIDENT TRUMP
OVER MILITARY DRILLS GOING ON
RIGHT NOW INVOLVING THE U.S. AND
SOUTH KOREA.
>> Greg: THAT IS SO DONALD.
IT SHOCKED THE MEDIA.
IF YOU READ ONE SENTENCE FROM
TRUMP'S BOOK, YOU WOULD KNOW
THAT NEGOTIATIONS DON'T PROCEED
WITHOUT SUCH ANTICS.
MORE WILL COME.
IT IS NOT LIKE TRUMP DIDN'T
PREPARE YOU FOR IT.
>> WE ARE MOVING ALONG VERY
NICELY WITH NORTH KOREA.
WE'LL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
IT'S TAKEN A LONG TIME, MANY,
MANY DECADES TO GET HERE.
LET'S SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE ARE DOING VERY WELL, AS YOU
KNOW, I NORTH KOREA.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE HAVEN'T SEEN ANYTHING.
WE HAVEN'T HEARD ANYTHING.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
WE'LL SEE.
TIME WILL TELL.
>> Greg: WE'LL SEE WHAT
HAPPENS.
THAT MONTAGE WAS FOR THOSE WHO
THINK TRUMP IS BEING PLAYED OR
BETTER HE LOOKS OUT FOR THEM
BRINGS WORLD PEACE, RIGHT,
MEDIA?
>> UTTERLY PREDICTABLE.
THE PRESIDENT WAS SO EAGER TO
ACCEPT THE TERMS BEFORE THE
TEAMS WERE SPELLED OUT.
>> IS A POSSIBLE KIM JONG UN
REALIZES HE'S GOT EVERYTHING
HE'S ALREADY WANTED WHICH IS
RECOGNITION ON THE WORLD STAGE.
>> DID PRESIDENT TRUMP MAKE UP
MISTAKEN AS OPTIMISM IN HIS
UPCOMING SUMMIT?
>> Greg: WET BLANKETS.
WE COME AT THIS WITH HEAVY
SKEPTICISM.
WITH TRUMP, WE TRUSTEE IS NOT
FULL OF ROSY OPTIMISM DRIVEN BY
A SELFISH LEGACY.
HE WIELDS A REALISTIC, NOT JUST
A YUMMY CARROT.
THE REASONS TO BE OPTIMISTIC,
EVEN WITH THE NORTH KOREAN
THREATS.
I WOULD BE MORE UNCERTAIN
WITHOUT SUCH THREATS.
IT IS A SIGN OF ENGAGEMENT.
GRANTED, FOR THIS DEAL TO
HAPPEN, YOU HAVE TO THINK BIG
AND BELIEVE YOU CAN ACTUALLY
PULL IT OFF.
TAKE A WAY SMALLER ACHIEVEMENT,
A MANHATTAN ATTRACTION THAT
LANGUISHED FOR YEARS BECAUSE THE
CITY COULDN'T GET IT RUNNING.
TRUMP GOT INVOLVED AND IN
MONTHS, HE TURNED IT INTO A
WILDLY POPULAR TOURIST
ATTRACTION.
WHY DOES THAT HAPPEN?
BECAUSE SOME GUY THOUGHT HE
COULD DO IT.
DO NOT UNDERESTIMATE THE POWER
OF POSITIVE THINKING ESPECIALLY
COMING FROM SOMEONE WHO KNOWS
THE GOOD GUY FROM THE BAD AND
HOW TO SPEAK BOTH THEIR
LANGUAGES.
HAVEN'T WE SEEN RESULTS ALREADY?
TODAY NORTH KOREA THREATENED TO
CANCEL A MEETING.
MONTHS AGO THEY WERE THREATENING
TO NUKE US.
I CALL THAT PROGRESS.
DAN, DANA, DANA.
>> Dana: WHEN YOU'RE DEALING
WITH THE NORTH KOREANS, I THINK
THIS IS HOW IT WORKS.
WE DON'T KNOW A LOT ABOUT
KIM JONG UN BECAUSE IT'S CALLED
THE HERMIT KINGDOM FOR A REASON.
AND I DO THINK THERE'S GOING TO
BE SOME CURVEBALLS ALONG THE
WAY.
I DO THINK THE PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN PRETTY CAUTIOUS.
HE HAS BEEN OPTIMISTIC AND
THROWING SOME COLD WATER ON IT
AT THE SAME TIME.
ALMOST EVERYTHING HE SAYS, NOT
EVERY TIME.
IF THERE'S CRITICISM ABOUT THAT
I THINK IF YOU LOOK AT THE
TOTALITY OF THE STATEMENTS OVER
A PERIOD OF TIME, HE'S BEEN, WE
WILL SEE.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Jesse: WE HAD A LOT ON THE
CUTTING ROOM FLOOR I THINK.
>> Dana: I DON'T THINK THE
PRESIDENT IS GOING TO OVERREACT
BECAUSE THEY NORTH KOREANS NEED
THE SUMMIT A LOT MORE THAN
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES.
HE CAN SIT BACK AND WAIT.
I THINK THE PRESIDENT WAS
CRITICAL OF PRESIDENT OBAMA'S OR
APPROACH DEALING WITH IRAN
BECAUSE PRESIDENT OBAMA LOOKED
MORE DESPERATE THAN THE IRANIANS
MORE DESPERATE THAN THE IRANIAN
IRANIANS.
IT LOOKED LIKE WE WERE MORE
INTERESTED IN GETTING THIS DONE
AND RUSHING THROUGH THE END.
THAT'S NOT HAPPENING HERE.
THE BEGINNING OF THE SECOND YEAR
FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP.
THE OTHER KEY FACTOR HERE IS THE
SOUTH KOREANS.
I KNOW THAT THE CHINESE ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT FOR THE
SOUTH KOREANS WANT THIS MORE
THAN ANYTHING.
PRESIDENT MOON IS GOING TO BE
COMING TO THE WHITE HOUSE ON
TUESDAY, SO THE PRESIDENT WILL
HAVE A CHANCE TO MEET WITH HIM
FACE-TO-FACE.
I DO THINK IT WAS A GOOD THING
THAT PRESIDENT MOON SAID WE ARE
NOT GOING TO STOP THESE DRILLS
WITH THE UNITED STATES BECAUSE
THAT SAYS TO KIM JONG UN THAT
HE'S GOING TO HAVE TO COME TO
THE TABLE, AND I BET HE WILL.
>> Greg: JESSE, DO YOU HAVE
ANY THEORIES BEHIND THIS?
>> Jesse: I DO.
THEY DON'T INVOLVE DENNIS
RODMAN.
I THINK HE IS FLEXING, POSTURING
TO MAKE IT LOOK LIKE MAXIMUM
PRESSURE DIDN'T BRING HIM TO THE
NEGOTIATING TABLE BUT IT DID
BECAUSE WE HAD UNILATERAL
SANCTIONS WE SLAPPED ON.
MAKING THE BLOCKADE OVER CERTAIN
VESSELS.
THE FUNERAL WAS DRYING UP.
LIMITED ACCESS TO CAPITAL.
THAT WAS ALL GOOD, THE TRUTH OF
WHY THIS HAS HAPPENED.
YES, HE DID SAY SOME GOOD
THINGS.
HE SAID WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THE
HOSTAGES BACK.
WE ARE GOING TO DESTROY THIS
NUCLEAR TESTING SITE.
SATELLITE IMAGERY PROVES IT'S
BEING DECOMMISSIONED.
COULD BE AN ACCIDENT THAT
DECOMMISSIONED IT.
GOOD THINGS WERE HAPPENING.
I DON'T LIKE THE MEDIA COMING IN
NOW ALMOST IN GLEE THAT THERE IS
A HICK UP TOWARDS PEACE JUST TO
HURT THE PRESIDENT.
TO ACT LIKE THAT PRESIDENT HAS
BEEN PUNKED WHEN I THINK THE
LAST COUPLE PRESIDENTS HAVE
BEEN.
TRUMP GAVE UP NOTHING.
HE SAID ANYTHING COULD HAPPEN.
HE SAYS SOMETHING INTERESTING
ABOUT JOHN BOLTON.
HE SAID JOHN BOLTON WAS
REPUGNANT.
>> Dana: KIM JONG UN SAID
THAT, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
>> Jesse: YES.
THIS IS A GUY WHO BURNED HIS
UNCLE IN ACID.
TO CALL HIM REPUGNANT WAS
HILARIOUS.
>> I WOULD WEAR THAT LIKE A
BADGE OF HONOR.
IF KIM JONG UN CALLED ME
REPUGNANT, I WOULD PUT IT ON A
SHIRT.
HE >> Jesse: SAYING THAT WE
SHOULD DEAL WITH NORTH KOREA
LIKE WE DID IN LIBYA.
LIBYA GAVE THEIR NUCLEAR STUFF
TO US AND THEN A COUPLE YEARS
LATER WE INVADED AND KILLED THEM
LATER WE INVADED AND KILLED THE
THEM.
WE LEAD FROM BEHIND.
>> Greg: I TRUST YOU ENJOYED
THIS VIEW MUCH BETTER.
[LAUGHTER]
>> WELL PLAYED.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE ON ALL THIS.
>> I DON'T THINK THE SUMMIT IS
THE BE-ALL AND END-ALL.
THE SUMMIT IS A GOOD PHOTO OP.
YOU SEE THEM SHAKING HANDS AND
THEY ARE SITTING DOWN AT THE
TABLE.
I THINK KIM JONG UN THOUGHT HE
WAS HOLDING ALL THE CARDS.
YOU COULD SAY I DON'T LIKE
BOLTON I'M NOT GOING TO DO THIS
IF YOU EXPECT ME TO DISARM.
HE IS NOT HOLDING THE CARDS
ANYMORE BECAUSE HE'S DEALING
WITH SOMEONE WHO WAS A PRETTY
STRONG HISTORY OF BEING A TOUGH
NEGOTIATOR.
I WANT TO REMIND THE MEDIA WHEN
YOU'RE PRESIDENT IS GOING UP
AGAINST KIM JONG UN, YOU SHOULD
BE ROOTING FOR YOUR PRESIDENT.
NOT SURPRISING THEIR BEHAVIOR.
I THINK DONALD TRUMP IS DOING
EXACTLY WHAT HE SHOULD BE DOING.
UNFETTERED AND SAY MY END GOAL
IS THE SAME.
I'M GOING TO BE TOUGH ON YOU.
I'M NOT GOING TO STOP TALKING
ABOUT YOU AND HUMAN RIGHTS
VIOLATIONS.
I'M GOING TO STAY TRUE TO
AMERICAN VALUES.
THAT'S THE BEST HE CAN DO.
IF THE SUMMIT DOESN'T HAVE
EMPLOYER NOT GOING TO CHANGE OUR
PHILOSOPHY BECAUSE WE ARE THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA.
>> Greg: JUAN, YOU ARE TELLING
ME IN THE GREEN ROOM THAT IN A
SENSE DONALD TRUMP ALREADY WON.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: I THINK THAT WAS
REPUGNANT.
YOU KNOW WHAT I AM STRUCK BY IS
THAT YOU GUYS SAY IT IS THE
LIBERAL PRESS THAT SEEMS TO BE
THE LIGHTING IN THE MOMENT OR
SUGGESTION THAT THIS MIGHT NOT
COME OFF.
TO MY MIND, IT'S THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA THAT WAS SO
QUICK TO SAY YOU KNOW WHAT, THIS
GUY IS GOING TO GET A NOBEL
PEACE PRIZE.
THIS WILL BE HIS SIGNATURE
FOREIGN AFFAIRS A COMPLIMENT.
SEEMS TO ME LIKE THAT WAS A
LITTLE BIT PREMATURE.
I THINK HE'S HAD A TOUGH WEEK.
I KNOW IT'S NOT GOING TO BE
AGREED UPON AT THIS TABLE BUT
YOU THINK ABOUT WHAT HAPPENED
THIS WEEK IN TERMS OF PULLING
OUT OF THE IRAN DEAL WHICH IS
NOT POPULAR WITH THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
THE EFFORT TO MOVE THE EMBASSY
TO JERUSALEM, LOTS OF DEATH.
YOU HAVE A DIFFERENT VIEW.
>> BY HAMAS.
>> Greg: I LIKE YOUR CHAMPION.
>> Juan: I ACKNOWLEDGE THAT
YOU GUYS ARE SMART.
THE THIRD POINT IS THE THING
ABOUT THE CHINESE COMPANY.
HE'S OFF ON HIS OWN.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
HERE COMES THIS MOMENT AND I
AGREE WITH YOU, AMERICANS SHOULD
BE ROOTING FOR PRESIDENT TRUMP
TO DO SOMETHING HERE BECAUSE
NORTH KOREA IS A THREAT TO WORLD
PEACE.
HAVE A NUCLEAR WEAPON.
BUT THE THING ABOUT IT IS, AND
THIS IS MY CONCERN.
I THINK WORLD LEADERS THINK THEY
CAN PLAY DONALD TRUMP.
THEY CAN GIVE HIM A BIG PARADE.
FLATTER HIM.
TELL HIM THEY LOVE --
>> Greg: EXAMPLES ABOUT ISRAEL
AND IRAN.
IT'S A CONTRADICTION.
THOSE SHOW THAT YOU CAN'T.
THE PARIS TREATY.
>> Dana: I WAS GOING TO SAY
ONE EXAMPLE WAS THE YOU HAD
MACRON AND ANGELA MERKEL AND
BORIS JOHNSON.
THEY SAID PLEASE DON'T PULL OUT
OF THE IRAN DEAL AND HE DID IT
ANYWAY.
THE SAME CAST OF CHARACTERS AND
MORE ON THE PARIS CLAIMANT
ACCORD IS KIND OF THE SAME DEAL.
SLATTERY MIGHT GET YOU GOOD
PRESS WITH THE PRESIDENT BUT IT
DOESN'T NECESSARILY GET YOU THE
RESULTS YOU WANT.
>> Juan: I THINK IN THIS CASE
THE CONSERVATIVE MEDIA, BEING SO
HUNGRY FOR THE NOBEL PRIZE.
KIM JONG UN IS SAYING IF THAT IS
THE CASE, HE DOESN'T WANT TO
MISS THIS MEETING.
HE NEEDS IT MORE THAN I DO.
THEREFORE IF I SAY CANCEL YOUR
JOINT MILITARY EXERCISES,
PRESIDENT TRUMP WILL BE UNDER
PRESSURE TO DO IT.
WE WILL SEE WHAT HAPPENS.
>> Jesse: WE ARE NOT HUNGRY
FOR THE PEACE PRIZE.
WE ARE HUNGRY FOR PEACE.
IT'S A NICE TROPHY TO SHOVE IN
THE LEFT'S FACE.
OBAMA'S PEACE PRIZE WAS A
PARTICIPATION TROPHY.
>> Jedediah: YOU COULD ARGUE
THAT GETTING PLAYED WAS SIGNING
ONTO A DEAL LIKE THE IRAN DEAL
WHICH ENDED UP HELPING THEM I
WAS A MINOR BAND-AID
TEMPORARILY.
>> Dana: CAN I ADD ONE LAST
THING.
THE ISSUE OF DENUCLEARIZATION
AND WHAT THAT MEANS IS A KEY
ISSUE.
I COME THAT'S WHY I'M SKEPTICAL
IF THERE WILL ACTUALLY BE IN
AGREEMENT.
>> Jesse: ADVISED TIME.
DENUCLEARIZATION IN 15 YEARS.
MEANWHILE HE HIDES ALL OF THE
SITES AND ALL OF A SUDDEN IN TEN
YEARS, HE HAS NUCLEAR
CAPABILITIES.
>> Dana: IF WE ARE GOING TO
GIVE ECONOMIC AID, I WANT TO
KNOW WHO'S GOING TO GET IT.
THE PEOPLE OR HIS REGIME AND THE
CRONIES?
>> Jedediah: YOU BRING UP A
GREAT POINT ABOUT THE
INSPECTIONS.
EVEN IF THEY AGREE TO THE
DENUCLEARIZATION EVERYBODY'S ON
THE SAME PAGE, HOW DO YOU
GUARANTEE?
>> Jesse: NOT SELF INSPECTIONS